okay let's talk about this beating up
these chicks
um this is feelings no facts feelings
yeah we're going to feel these no facts
because it's already to the point where
i just want to throw away everything
i want to throw away everything we're at
the point where it's like what's the
point of a career let's just make it all
explode okay let's just go down let's go
down in a ball of flames okay
um
no but let's talk about it this is this
is this is an interesting story because
these things keep on popping up and
nobody seems to want to address it and
you know who they never ask uh how they
feel about this or maybe they do we just
never hear we always hear about like
these like uh right wing pundits are
always talking about it the left wing
doesn't really say anything because they
know that it's [ __ ] up but they can't
really be anti-trans so the right-wing
guys used it as a way to like kind of
push back against trans rights i think
it's kind of like a community push back
against over-correction i think more so
they're pushing back against what they
feel is like the the pc movement
overreaching
and this is the one that they they think
they have the easiest time arguing
because it kind of also flips their
feminism argument against them yes and
it's like if you have a trans woman in
the women's bathroom yeah that's enough
for conservatives or to go yo this is
[ __ ] up but liberals would be like you
have to respect her as a woman she just
go you as a bathroom as a woman it is
what it is
once you get
violence into the equation right then
all of a sudden there has to be a little
bit of pushback like do you want these
[ __ ] being beat up by a dude who's
like an ex-navy seal right like the dude
was literally ex-military yeah there's a
there's a picture of him before he
transitioned where he's looking like
[ __ ] gordon ryan dude do you know who
that is yeah
dude yeah the jiu-jitsu goat the guy was
[ __ ] stacked when he was a dude
transitioned to the chick still in
pretty good shape but there's a there's
an image of him [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of this girl yeah so what i'm
curious about is
what the girls that are fighting these
trans women think
yeah i would love to hear that that's
all i want to hear i just want to hear
the girls like do they look at it as a
challenge are they really willing to
test their fighting skills are they
going i'm a martial artist it doesn't
matter who you put in front of me are
they going you know what i'm saying i
actually watched a cnn interview this
was a few years ago it's probably like
six or seven years ago the fallon fox
story probably fallen fox fighters
someone that fought fallon fox that was
like yeah like the cnn reporter was just
kind of asking about the fight and they
were like yeah you know it was good like
good competitor blah blah and started
trying to bait the conversation into a
trans issue yeah where the fighter
didn't really seem like she was
interested in talking about trans
fighting yeah and then kind of got like
baited into it and then like kind of
misspoke and was afraid of getting
canceled i think if you're a high level
competitor
you're just thinking i don't care i want
to fight them and i'm not going to have
any excuses where you could talk to me
all you want about bone density and all
this advantage that person might have
had for
this person 30 years of being a male
genetically yeah whatever sexually
whatever but i don't want
i just see that as competition and i
should win and that's it there's also a
weird steroid i think a competitor might
be like let's not even let that [ __ ]
that is an excuse enter into my mind win
or lose i win or lost and that's it
like a high level competitor might be
like [ __ ] all the excuses let's just go
because i'm sure the rules are the same
as the olympics where like they just got
to make sure that your testosterone is
within a female range right right so if
we're basing your strength and ability
strictly on testosterone right which i
think is unfair because there's probably
other things that go into it but it's
like a testosterone estrogen level right
that's what makes you quote unquote
female or be able to compete with these
females i just don't subscribe and maybe
it's my sexism like i don't care if i'm
a dude that has no testosterone in my
body at all like
no girl's going to beat me up like yeah
even if she's got testosterone
yeah right like i i i know that sex is
to say but i believe it's completely
unfair well this is where it gets weird
because there's a steroids thing that
happens okay where a lot of these
fighters men and women are on steroids
oh yeah yeah yeah so they're like yo do
you want to fight a trans woman and
they're like okay yeah it's the same
weight class like maybe they got more
muscle more bone density whatever but
their estrogen is higher and their
testosterone is lower and i'm on [ __ ]
testosterone so don't start testing
testosterone because my testosterone is
crazy or like i had to cycle in the
offseason and then i got off it and
started using beta blockers or whatever
you're saying the female competitors
yeah exactly right are on the steroids
female for like the genetically female
ones so in a weird way it kind of
exposes testosterone use in female
athletes or female mma fighters at least
because they're like well [ __ ] don't
test it for testosterone because it's
going to expose me that i've been
[ __ ] cheating as well and then on top
of that they're like you got to measure
clits i think i think it's got to be
dick or [ __ ] it has to be in like the
one centimeter or three centimeter range
yeah and then you're good but if you
have like a full [ __ ]
like if you're just if you're just all
like foreskin
if that's all that's left like your
actual like phallus has just kind of
shriveled away yeah i think you can beat
with women yeah i'm okay with just like
a hand and like a pantyhose kind of
thing yeah
just real floppy yeah
like if you turned like a like a smurf
upside down like you know those hats
that they have yeah yeah yeah yeah oh we
think or am i thinking of a keebler elf
you're thinking of a kebab keebler elf
yeah just that if that's it i think you
can go
but micro penis
yeah i guess
oh my god talking about micro
and then we get back to the story real
quick you know how like dwarfism is a
thing and gigantism is a thing
right you've gigantism you've all heard
right has there ever been a dwarf with
gigantism
i don't think you can maybe maybe one of
us dwarfs tend to have no because they'd
have that same body it would just be
[ __ ] like a giant toddler yes
dwarves tend to have small hands with
big head
i don't know small legs small alarms
because i don't think that things are
opposite i think they're two different
diseases and they're they're just so
rare that it oh my god you almost never
see please tell me there is one right
now adam rainer get the [ __ ] out of 1899
was the only person recorded history to
have been both a dwarf and a giant are
there pictures yeah holy [ __ ] that's why
so his adult height was 4 foot 10 inches
oh
but
that was a gigantism a dwarf so it was
supposed to be two feet
no i think anything under fi 411 is
considered a [ __ ] yeah this was
hold on oh no four foot
no no he was a it was a regular adult oh
he ended up reaching a height of seven
foot holy [ __ ] does the body look like
a [ __ ] still
kind of mark please just please put this
on i'm putting up a pic
whoa
that's wild no that's just a regular guy
he's a dwarf
he's wearing a v-line
door
he's going something's going on with his
face dude [ __ ] chimney sweep
okay back to but back to the what's it
called the fighter thing what is what is
your so i read about this particular
fighter and this is where i have a
little more empathy or sympathy or
whatever the word is for her this trans
is because she came out in 2003 as trans
before there was a big pc movement we
were all pretty [ __ ] close-minded
about this stuff she was like yo i'd
like to
have the surgery her parents said no
so she ended up like going to war as a
male then had ptsd all this [ __ ] and
still want to do the surgery so this is
like sometimes i think you can question
their motives like what are you just
trying to [ __ ] compete and win and
where you're trying to beat girls up
yeah you know like dexter found a way to
kill people right he's like i'll just
kill bad people because i need to do it
right like if you're a guy who just
needs to beat women up yeah then you
transition to a woman and then compete
in female mma and i don't think this is
one of those cases because they you made
them stay a man and they went to [ __ ]
war they're like yeah i just whatever
yeah also i was thinking about this
issue and i was thinking won't this just
sort itself out with enough time like if
trans athletes keep transitioning and
then dominating and winning and like
taking all the championships and every
woman's sport we're going to eventually
like give this [ __ ] got to stop
yeah it's like shaq made you change the
rules basketball exactly right so
there's going to be like a girl so we're
going to do this every time and i get it
but if you step back can't just be like
this will take care of itself this is
one of those problems that you just let
it go and eventually everybody would
like you know the only issue is if it
was regular sports
i think that people don't care enough
about female sports most female sports
there's a few but like right people
don't care enough about female sports uh
to to really like make the adjustments
to the changes well people within the
federations do pardon if you're leading
the women's ufc federation or the
women's mma federation you care enough
about women's sports you would adjust it
yeah but like in general like i don't
think that like
female sports outside of like maybe like
uh tennis don't drive enough revenue for
there to be like real changes right
female sports for the most part in on
the professional level it is it sounds
[ __ ] up to say but it's more of like a
charity case it's like uh the nba is
gonna front the money for the wnba it's
not a profitable business endeavor but
it's the right thing to do so we can get
more women into the sport and maybe the
nba is looking like hey look if women
are actually into the wnba that means
they're definitely going to be in the
nba as well and then we can double our
market share by getting the other half
of the population of care right
if this was happening to men's sports if
women were better than men and they were
coming in and affecting the game
please
realize that this would be changed
immediately right
in a [ __ ] heartbeat so maybe you're
right maybe it sorts itself out when it
enters the ufc right maybe it's like
when amanda nunes gets knocked the [ __ ]
out by some guy who used to be a [ __ ]
navy seal right then all of a sudden we
go what is happening over here but
fallon fox lost
yeah right right a girl beat her right
you know so uh i again i don't think you
see that change that hits highest level
i think the only tricky thing is akash
is that if this was
if this was any other sport where where
they don't actually get like hurt and
potentially killed
i think it'd be okay to just let it
sword itself right this is a violent
sport one girl could die man yeah the
weird thing i see is every time this
story hits uh the news cycle it's either
the media talking about it or men
right never really yeah women have to
speak up
yeah until women speak up we're not
gonna do [ __ ]
and what do you think the hesitation is
uh
they have the pushback of
saying hey i don't wanna compete against
trans but they're so progressive
so the liberal women want to include
trans women
in what it is to be a woman
but they are also
scared of excluding them and competing
against women yeah so they're just quiet
yeah and since it's not happening at a
large scale like there's so few trans
people in general
there's even
less that are competing in sports and
even fewer that are competing even close
to the highest level right
yeah you know what i mean it's like
having a [ __ ] ufc champion from like
british samoa right
it's just so hard and that's why men
care about it because we're like nah
[ __ ] gotta be fair so we're not even
watching the [ __ ] trans fight but
we're just like nah that [ __ ] don't
sound fair and
if we're going to look at ourselves in
the best possible way like i don't think
we'd like to see women get their ass
kicked by guys that's also true like but
i don't know i don't know why death is
the inhibiting factor if that's an
outcome in any ufc fight or any mma
fight right like death is always on the
table for any fight right yeah this guy
could be at a genetic advantage or
whatever uh yeah but if they're the same
weight class how different is it
well
i mean you know if they're both fighting
on 130 though there's a lot of like a
guy at 130 and a girl 130 aren't the
same right but on like estrogen blockers
and all that [ __ ] i'm like that's the
thing that we don't know we don't know
if a guy's testosterone levels reduced
to the like to a woman's testosterone
it's gonna be the same i mean so what
she said is i can't bench as much as i
used to i went from running a six minute
mile to a nine minute mile now i think
she used to bench like 350 as a male and
now she's at like 185 or whatever so she
said it affected her performance there's
a video you linked us to and the guy was
using all kinds of terms i don't [ __ ]
understand but he basically said he said
bone density a bunch of other things are
going to come into play just from having
been a male for 30 years yeah that just
reducing testosterone isn't going to
take away right you're still going to
have all these other secondary
advantages right and can't the woman
choose to take the fight though yeah of
course they can of course again but um
yeah i mean look there's other factors
that go into that like they want to make
a living they want to do right by the
promotion they're contractually
obligated to take fights and if they say
no then maybe the promotion looks down
on them the promotion is also selfishly
going hey if we have this fight here the
whole world is going to be talking about
it and we're going to get named in it so
they're probably not looking out for
that girl as much but even going back to
like the testosterone numbers like have
you ever had like an old man like grab
you yeah they got ole miss drinks old
man strength is a thing it's a real
thing we all know this right like that
old man like offensive line this guy at
the ymca was like 60 like smaller than
any of us that were there and lifting
way more than he was yeah and even guys
that aren't exercising like just grandpa
that just grabs and holds you he's got
[ __ ] cuts in his fingers who haven't
healed for like 20 years like that guy's
testosterone levels are super low like
you get older i think naturally your
testosterone goes down that's why they
do trt right testosterone replacement
therapy and people start that even
earlier [ __ ] i know people that aren't
[ __ ] trt and they're in their late
30s right so dak shepard is on it
there's a lot of famous people on it so
it's like if those testosterone levels
already dipped but that old man still
got that [ __ ] strength like no
grandma's ever grabbed me and i was like
damn [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] all right
all right happy birthday all right
i'll come around more often yeah right
so there's got to be something else
besides just testosterone and weight
that's giving a guy an advantage in a
fight with a girl
and that's where i think the issue is to
answer your question and what are those
things is it just muscle like maybe bone
density thing i don't know like we need
a science nerd to come on over here but
we never had to cross this uh you know
uh bridge because um everybody kind of
was on the same [ __ ] page like we're
like all right the reason why we have
two different sports
you know we don't let girls compete it
was really generous of us to be like hey
don't play in our league because we'll
[ __ ] we still watch all
let's create some rules so you could
play
if a man in nunes wanted to fight a guy
in the same weight class or whatever and
they were both like yeah let's fight
would anyone care
well i think there'd be a lot of people
that we're not happy with there is
someone who's trying to do this some
little ufc fighters dude is trying to
fight a big girl i forget somebody dm me
about this a while ago oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i don't know if it's going to
happen though they keep promoting it as
if it's going to happen but i don't know
you don't have a problem with nunes
fighting to do
if they were an mma fighter like if she
was fighting another elite mma fighter
i'd have a problem if she was fighting
like a random dude off the street who
thought he could beat amanda yeah
buddy yeah good luck yeah but if she
challenges another mma fighter
i i i just don't like she's just
dominating everybody
all of her competition is like yo i need
some more confidence i don't even like i
don't even like seeing women
fight like it's gross to me dog
i'm with you wait
like seeing them like fighting like
they're bleeding and [ __ ] heads all
swollen and [ __ ] like it's uncomfortable
but some of those fights have been
incredible yeah but they should be
should they be allowed to huh should
they be allowed anything that makes me
uncomfortable should be alive
that's a curate society based on your
comfort
you